con otras décadas. La década del 2000
es la única en la que al final
había menos personas trabajando que
al principio. Eso no es lo que queremos.
Cuando dibujamos el número de personas en edad laboral
y el número de empleos en el país, vemos que
la brecha es cada vez mayor
y que en la Gran Recesión se agrandó mucho más
Hice algunos cálculos. Tomé los últimos 20 años del crecimiento del PIB
y del crecimiento de la productividad laboral,
y los usé de manera sencilla para tratar
de prever cuántos empleos necesitará la economía
para seguir creciendo, y esta es la línea que conseguí.
¿Buena o mala? Este es el pronóstico del gobierno
para la población en edad laboral.
Si estas predicciones son correctas, la distancia no va a disminuir.
El problema es que no creo que sean exactas.
De hecho, pienso que mi previsión es demasiado optimista,
porque cuando la hice, supuse que el futuro
sería como el pasado respecto al crecimiento
de la productividad laboral, pero yo ya no lo creo así.
Cuando miro a mi alrededor, pienso que todavía no hemos visto
nada del impacto que la tecnología puede tener en la población activa.
En el último par de años, hemos visto cómo herramientas digitales
demostraban habilidades que nunca antes habían poseído.
Y eso tiene que ver mucho con nuestros trabajos de humanos.
Déjenme ponerles un par de ejemplos.
Durante toda la historia, si querías traducir algo
de una lengua a otra,
necesitabas a una persona.
Ahora tenemos servicios de traducción automática
multilingues, instantáneos y gratuitos
en muchos de nuestros dispositivos, incluido los teléfonos inteligentes.
Y si los han usado, sabrán que no son perfectos,
pero bastante decentes.
Durante toda la historia, si querías un artículo
o un informe, necesitabas a una persona en el proceso.
Ya no. Este artículo sobre las ganancias de Apple apareció
en Forbes en línea hace un tiempo.
Lo escribió un algoritmo.
No es decente: es perfecto.
Muchos ven esto y dicen: "Vale,
eso son tareas muy específicas y concretas
y la mayoría de trabajadores del conocimiento son generalistas;
usan su maestría y un amplio conocimiento
de muchos temas para reaccionar rápidamente
a problemas impredecibles. Y eso es muy muy
difícil que lo haga un autómata".
Uno de los trabajadores del conocimiento
más impresionantes es Ken Jennings.
Ganó el concurso "Jeopardy!" 74 veces seguidas
y se llevó USD 3 millones.
Este es Ken a la derecha después de ser vencido tres a uno
por Watson, el superordenador de IBM diseñado para jugar.
Cuando vemos lo que la tecnología puede llegar
a conseguir, empiezo a plantearme que quizás
ser un generalista no es algo tan especial,
sobre todo cuando conseguimos conectarle Siri
a Watson de manera que puede
entender lo que decimos
y respondernos hablando.
Siri está lejos de la perfección y podríamos reírnos
de sus defectos, pero debemos ser conscientes de que
si las tecnologías como Siri y Watson mejoran
siguiendo la ley de Moore, y pasará,
en seis años no serán dos veces mejores ni cuatro,
serán 16 veces mejores que ahora.
Me di cuenta de que muchos trabajadores del conocimiento se verían afectados.
Y las tecnologías digitales no sólo afectan a este ámbito,
sino que se están inmiscuyendo también en el mundo real.
Hace poco tuve la oportunidad de probar el auto
autónomo de Google, tan divertido como suena. (Risas)
Y les garantizo que sobrellevó los atascos
de la autopista 101 bastante bien.
Tres millones y medio de personas
se ganan la vida como camioneros en los EE. UU.
Creo que esta tecnología afectará a algunos.
Y por el momento, los androides son muy primitivos.
No pueden hacer mucho.
Pero mejoran rápidamente. Y la DARPA,
que es la rama de inversiones del departamento de Defensa
intenta acelerar el proceso.
En resumen: los androides vienen a por nuestros trabajos.
A corto plazo, podemos estimular el aumento de empleos
promoviendo el espíritu emprendedor e invirtiendo
en infraestructuras, porque los robots todavía
no saben arreglar puentes.
Pero a medio plazo, creo que la mayoría de nosotros
lo veremos durante nuestras vidas, la economía va a transformarse
en una muy productiva
pero que no necesitará a muchos trabajadores humanos.
Gestionar esa transformación será el mayor reto
de nuestras sociedades.
Voltaire lo resumió así: "El trabajo nos protege de tres demonios:
el aburrimiento, el vicio y la necesidad".
Pero a pesar del reto, yo sigo siendo positivo
con respecto a la revolución digital,
y estoy seguro de que las tecnologías que desarrollamos ahora
crearán un futuro mejor, utópico,
no un distopía. Y para explicar las razones,
les propondré una pregunta demasiado general.
Quiero preguntarles cuáles han sido
los mayores avances de la historia humana.
Compartiré con Uds. algunas de las respuestas.
Es una pregunta interesantísima
para empezar un debate interminable,
y que algunos sugerirán que
los sistemas filosóficos de Occidente y de Oriente
han transformado nuestra manera de entender el mundo.
Otros lo negarán y propondrán
que los mayores avances fueron las religiones,
que han cambiado las civilizaciones
y han influido la forma de vivir de personas y países.
Otro dirá:
"No, lo que de verdad modifica las civilizaciones
y cambia la vida de las personas
son los imperios, así que los grandes avances humanos
son las conquistas y las guerras".
Y siempre hay alguna alma cándida que suelta:
"No se olviden de las plagas". (Risas)
Algunas respuestas son más optimistas:
la era de los exploradores y
la apertura del mundo.
Otros piensan en los logros intelectuales
como la matemática que nos han ayudado
a controlar mejor el mundo, y otros pensarán
en los periodos del florecimiento
de las ciencias y las artes. Y el debate puede seguir y seguir.
Es un debate interminable, sin conclusión,
sin una respuesta definitiva. Pero un cretino como yo
va y dice: "¿Qué dicen los datos?".
Y empezamos a hacer gráficas con cosas que nos interesan
como la población mundial, por ejemplo,
u otras medidas de desarrollo social
o el progreso social.
Empiezas a introducir los datos... Desde este punto de vista
las historias importantes serán
las que modifiquen significativamente las curvas.
Cuando introducimos los datos,
rápidamente obtenemos conclusiones curiosas.
Se concluye que nada de lo dicho antes
ha importado demasiado. (Risas)
No le han tocado un pelo a las curvas. (Risas)
La historia ha sido una, un solo gran desarrollo
en la historia de la humanidad modificó la curva
unos 90º: la tecnología.
El motor a vapor y otras tecnologías relacionadas
de la Revolución Industrial cambiaron el mundo
e influyeron tanto la vida humana,
que, en palabras del historiador Morris,
se burlaron de todo lo anterior.
Y lo hicieron al multiplicar por infinito el poder
de nuestros músculos, sobrepasando sus limitaciones.
Ahora presenciamos
la superación de las limitaciones de nuestros cerebros
y la multiplicación desorbitada de nuestro poder mental.
¿No es esto tan importante como la victoria
sobre nuestras limitaciones físicas?
Aunque me repita un poco, diré que
hoy día la tecnología digital
no acaba más que de empezar.
Y cuando observo nuestras economías
y nuestras sociedades, mi única conclusión es que
todavía no hemos visto nada. Lo bueno está aún por llegar.
Les pondré unos ejemplos.
La economía no la mueve ni la energía ni el capital
ni el trabajo. Son las ideas la que la hacen funcionar.
La innovación, la creación de nuevas ideas,
es una de las tareas más poderosas
y más fundamentales que podemos ejercer
en una economía. Y en eso se basa la innovación.
Tomamos a un grupo de gente parecida,
(Risas)
...los sacamos de unas instituciones de elite,
los ponemos en otras y esperamos la innovación.
(Risas)
Soy un blanco que solo ha estudiado en el MIT
y en Harvard, así que esto no me extraña. (Risas)
Pero otros creen que es demasiado
y han relajado la etiqueta un poco.
(Risas)
Estos son los ganadores de un concurso de programación Top Coder.
Les aseguro que
a nadie le importa dónde crecieron o a qué colegio fueron
o qué pinta tienen. Lo único que importa
es su trabajo, la calidad de sus ideas.
Y esto pasa cada vez más a menudo
en este mundo tecnológico.
La innovación cada vez es más accesible,
más inclusiva, más transparente y se basa más en el mérito.
Y eso seguirá así al margen de la opinión de el MIT o Harvard.
Ese cambio me hace muy feliz.
A veces alguien dice: "Vale. En eso tienes razón,
pero la tecnología es todavía algo de ricos,
pero estas herramientas no están mejorando
la vida de la base de la pirámide".
Yo les respondo: estupideces.
Los pobres se benefician muchísimo de la tecnología.
El economista Robert Jensen hizo un estudio estupendo
donde analizaba en detalle
qué pasaba en Kerala, un pueblo pesquero de la India,
cuando accedieron a celulares por primera vez.
Cuando se publica en el "Quarterly Journal of Economics",
se usa un lenguaje muy formal y circunspecto,
pero al leer su artículo, notaba que Jensen
estaba gritándonos que era algo importante.
Los precios se estancaron, entonces se podía planear la economía familiar.
Los desechos no se redujeron; se eliminaron.
Y la vida de compradores y vendedores
mejoró de manera medible.
Puede que piensen que Jensen tuvo suerte
y que encontró las únicas aldeas
que se han beneficiado de la tecnología.
Pero lo que él ha hecho es documentar con detalles
lo que pasa una y otra vez
cuando la tecnología llega a una nueva comunidad.
La vida de las personas, su bienestar, mejora muchísimo.
Cuando veo las pruebas
y veo el camino que nos queda, me vuelvo
un optimista digital y pienso
que la declaración del físico Freeman Dyson
no es una hipérbole. Es una evaluación adecuada de lo que pasa.
Nuestras tecnologías son importantes regalos
y ahora mismo somos muy afortunados
de estar viviendo en la época de la tecnología digital,
cuando se extienda y abarque
cada vez más lugares en el mundo.
Sí, los robots nos quitan el trabajo,
pero quedarnos en eso es equivocarnos.
Lo importante es que así nos queda tiempo para hacer otras cosas.
Y lo que haremos, estoy seguro,
será reducir la pobreza, los trabajos duros
y la miseria del mundo. Estoy seguro de que
aprenderemos a vivir más tranquilos
y estoy seguro de que lo que conseguiremos
con la nueva tecnología digital será tan impactante
y beneficioso, que todo lo anterior parecerá
un chiste a su lado.
La última palabra se la dejaré a alguien capital
para el progreso digital,
nuestro viejo amigo Ken Jennings. Lo apoyo.
Repetiré sus palabras:
"Yo sí le doy la bienvenida a los nuevos ciberseñores". (Risas)
Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)